hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to netflix and chill' the game
now believe it or not I've never done
this Netflix and chill thing so I have
no idea what it means but I've heard
that it has to do with the ladies or the
men if you bring them back for Netflix
and chill
I don't know what happens but I'm an
expert at it because I'm an expert at
romancin I played huniepop which means
that I know how to seduce innate ok
anyway let's get into it so this game I
don't know I was recommended by you guys
ooh
the music is very good why do I have a
garage door in my living room that's
literally like it that's a loading dock
whoo hello hi has gone are you doing am
i seducing you oh boy my tinder date
will be here super soon man hope it goes
well oh I know what I'm supposed to do
I'm supposed to help this guy get laid
I can do just that just need to set a
few things oh you know booze a bag over
my head cuz I'm horrendously ugly all
right what do we got all right Netflix
is a go now all we need is the chill Wow
let me put on my suave shirt and get on
my Axe body spray
so that I can smell up this whole place
what are we doing that's a big-ass lamp
that lamps bigger than you are
what ah chill Austria so sexy my dates
here I can't wait to say hi door does my
hair look good does it ever not look
good do I have something in my teeth
yeah teeth let's go oh yeah I don't have
teeth Oh gross God this guy doesn't even
have a face here goes nothing you got
damn right I did
it's the first time you're dating this
girl why is she coming over to your
house that seems very strange usually
you'd gone to a nice restaurant or
something oh I'm supposed to do this
okay hi how's it going
you look lovely miss no face is weird
hug shake high-five
come on don't leave me hanging up top
yeah all right were you talking to
yourself a moment ago
I always do is that a problem yeah
absolutely so what if I was you got a
problem with it don't mess with me I
know how to live my life whoa no need to
get defensive I get defensive at all
times defense what are you talking about
screw you lady sure it's cool if you
were though I do it all the time oh
she's crazy too
yep not weird at all well come on in all
right
just have a seat on my gigantic couch by
my gigantic lab where we can watch
Netflix and chill so what are we
watching
um superhero I always always always
impresses the ladies I suppose you see
whoa whoa there Jason we only just met
let's get to know each other a bit
before making a commitment like that oh
okay I haven't been on a date in a while
so I don't know living my reclusive life
inside my industrial warehouse with a
loading dock I off and you know
sometimes forget what it's like to
actually talk to a woman so uh I just
realized that with these movie dates
it's kind of hard to get to know a
person you know couldn't agree more so
what do you say we move on yeah like
what ha I'll show you oh man make a move
yeah be bold you gotta be bold oh you
seem like a really guy
Gregson I just don't know you that well
yet let's see oh well I don't want to do
that that's just mean let's see withdraw
but don't apologize apologize is for
wimps
be bold about everything well you never
know if you don't try
yeah yeah I guess you're right I have an
idea how about we have a conversation
well that's usually an interesting
strategy for dates not usually would I
go about but let's do that
sure okay now what about Oh deep
intellectual discussion about society
that sounds boring oh god damn it down
with society oh yeah get into politics
on the first date down to the society
Anarchy Reigns I'm gonna get laid
of course society is great why is it
great they're quite the interviewer
you're the one making all the bold
statements okay Society is great because
we're making progress and [ __ ] that's
what we do as a people okay Wow
actually despite all the craziness in
the new man the constant fear and gloom
and doom it spits at us if you really
look at the numbers we're look like it
the best point in history I mean we have
the lowest child mortality rate of all
time women have more rights than ever
and so many people have internet access
now I'd say it's actually a pretty great
time to be alive Wow very inspirational
I'm so turned on right now
not her I'm talking about me
intellectual always gives me a brain
boner hey what do you say play a game
okay what do you have in mind let's play
truth or dare
always a great game to play on the first
date because you want to make them as
uncomfortable as possible
what is this sixth grade see you chicken
huh little baby girl don't want to admit
her deepest darkest flaws all right come
on bring it on bring it on okay true
works for me see Jason truth or dare
well I always like to go for truth first
because then it reveals my crushing
insecurities okay hotshot tell me what
do you think about me oh you're a babe
oh you still fine you're a babe so
little babe hundred percent ten now ten
babe levels no yeah I know how to talk
to the ladies when it's a
multiple-choice question on all my dates
which is what it has been for some
drained reason not because I only play
dating simulators
by toys so can I say I like how easy oh
and I like the things that are in front
of my face
yeah oh don't be so modest you're
gorgeous haha okay enough of that I
think my ego is gonna explode out of my
head if I get any more compliments haha
yeah we might as well just explode out
of these clothes huh
yeah okay I'll do truth - since you
didn't step it up while you had the
chance
oh I see how it is that's cool okay my
question for you is the Z Oh what do you
think of me huh you asked me that or
what do you think about me babe huh oh
no she's leaning annoying
um yeah you seem like a really great guy
dude what god dammit this [ __ ]
alright fine whatever never know if you
don't try
fine whatever oh we're gonna watch well
this is crap this load of [ __ ] this
dates almost silver and we aren't even
close to getting laid
I mean chilling just chilling nothing
it's about time I left what what oh okay
bye what have some laundry to do no come
on come on little bit I'm so lonely the
crushing emptiness of my industrial
warehouse gets to me sometimes I'm very
depressed Oh
I'm knackered setae t hey come on babe
let's see I really like you even though
I just met you if you walk out the door
I probably won't see you again sorry
Jason I just don't feel the same way
it's been fun
have a good night goodbye you too Marta
okay okay the end and then I lived out
the rest of my days in total solitude
not even another human being gave me the
time of day because I failed the Netflix
and chill so this time let's go bold
we're gonna go dare yeah dear me I'm on
glad to see you're not a wimp would you
be dating a wimp come on I'm so strong
and self-confident and definitely not
crippled by insecurity I dare you to uh
huh
what yeah hold on trying to think of a
good one okay first thing that comes to
mind any day now I dare you to do your
sexiest dance well I'm good at that I
could I'll do my best
ha you're joking right I'm not joking
that's the marklar mating dance
everybody write that one down
for when you're at the club cranking it
out
why would I be joking what you scared
see I don't want to scare you
why would I scare you because of my
amazing sexual abilities and dance nests
let's see science scared let me show you
here we go any day now let's go hammer
time mood torque okay I'm good with that
oh yeah oh yeah Oh mark he likes uh I
wanna date this guy oh yeah you're so
funny I am so funny I'm really funny I'm
a really funny guy what can I say but I
was born this way hold the applause
please okay so that's good I guess I
just need to remember not to make a move
because I just embarrassed myself by
twerking in front of a girl that I just
met because that's probably not
something I should do on the first date
anyway okay what is your deepest darkest
secret yes what's your deepest darkest
secret oh gee well that got intense
pretty quickly do you expect I just
worked my buttocks off well I'm waiting
haha okay when I was a little girl I
thought that carrot top was really hard
what Wow okay didn't expect that huh
that's a pretty dark secret I don't know
he was so confident in his weird
appearance I thought that was sexy I
guess that's a little girl AHS bizarre
remind me not to ask you any questions
like that again you asked for it
oh this is a good part let's get back to
the show
not fighting you there what do you mean
not fighting me there what did you we're
gonna do it have a good time
I accept your love of carrot top it's
okay hey guys
hey it's been nice but I think it's
about time I left
suzune lawyer
ah see I really like you
yeah maybe oh oh
I'm going for the kiss yeah meet me
halfway yeah all right
that's the chill part okay I think I can
stay a little while longer okay so I
hope you all were taking notes we'll
have a test on the third Wednesday of
this month I will go on a date with each
and every one of you individually to see
if you can seduce me so thank you
everybody so much for watching maybe
there's a secret Easter egg ending in
this game I don't know you can play it
through the link in the description
below as always and thank you everybody
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video